This video is brought to you by Squarespace from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the only one platform to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business.
Check out Squarespace through the link in the description below more on them.
Sure.
History is brimming with thousands of years of dynasties,
rebellions and civil Wars emperors came and the winds with the concrete
predictability of its early summer rainy season dynasties Rose
dynasties fell in nearly every case.
Those dynasties were run by men who ruled over a vast Asian empire
with an assortment of Hans pig, bureaucrats and concubines,
but in the middle of China's most beloved Imperial dynasty,
there was one woman who defied every expectation for herself.
She Rose from a simple palace concubine to Empress of China,
through a careful blends of understated intelligence,
ruthless decision-making and feminine Wiles.
These are the many names and titles of wounds.
[Inaudible].
Who is primarily referenced to by her surname was born on February the 17th in
the year 624 CE it was a good time to be a citizen of Imperial China.
This was the beginning of the Tang dynasty believed by many scholars in modern
day, Chinese to be the greatest dynasty ever produced by Imperial China.
The Tang emperors that perfected Chinese bureaucracy.
Thanks in part to a series of challenging entrance exams that selected and
recruited the most intelligent Chinese citizens and gave them jobs in the local
or national governments. As a result,
China was flourishing both culturally and economically.
We came from a wealthy family. Her father was Wu.
She whole chancellor for the emperor in the opening years of the Tang dynasty,
her mother known as lady yang came from another powerful family.
Even from a young age, we lived a very unusual life, a Chinese woman.
She was educated in music and politics.
She was also instructed in calligraphy and dabbled in a Chinese art form that
was gaining popularity at the time poetry as was the case across the world.
At the time, all of this education for a young girl was pretty atypical,
but Wu's uncommon intelligence combines with a powerful family of means made
for an atypical childhood to be short.
As we grew up the budding Imperial mind discovered she had another huge asset at
her disposal. She was quite beautiful. The combination of her raw intelligence,
educational backgrounds,
and unrivaled beauty made a quite unique and Imperial China.
It wasn't long before she was selected for a great honor. At the age of 14,
she was selected as the next concubine for emperor ties on now to our modern
Western standards.
Being plucked from one's home to live as an Imperial prostitute with special
privileges might not sound like a huge honor, but it's an Imperial China.
This was a big deal. Think of it like winning American beauty pageant,
except instead of getting a million new Instagram followers and day scholarship
to Arizona States, you got to have sex with the emperor. If you will,
feminist sensibilities, didn't like we was forced career choice your in.
You're not going to like this next boss. Emperor ties on has nine concubines.
And they all had rankings as if they were college basketball teams,
but we ranked death. She was still very beautiful,
but emperor ties on Brevard.
Some of his older longest standing consoles to her still.
We enjoyed certain benefits from an early life as a teenage concubine.
She was able to accompany ties on,
on certain trips throughout China acting as some sort of cross between a
girlfriend's obsessions and a secretary. When she wasn't on the road,
she lived on the Imperial palace grounds with the other concubines in the
capital city of Chiang on in central China.
At one point we disappointed ties on and he considered having her killed.
He only spent her because he felt she was too beautiful to die.
We continue to live what it become a normal life,
fulfilling her palace duties as a concubine does while growing closer to
legi the youngest of emperor Ty's songs, 14 sons.
Then when we was 25 and prioritize on died and legi replaced him as the new
Tang dynasty emperor under the name gals song,
while evidence does suggest that ties on and w had a sexual relationship,
she never bought any of his children by law.
All concubines of a deceased emperor had to leave the palace and take monastic
vows,
which is how the crafty Wu fell into residence at [inaudible] temple,
where she was pledged, observed the remainder of her life as a Buddhist nun.
However,
a relationship with the ascendent emperor gala zone came in handy for an
aspirational women like Wu on the anniversary of his father's death.
Gaussian visited the Buddhist monastery,
where we had been moved and when their eyes match,
the story goes that they cried together and remembrance of the former emperor,
realizing that he found Wu more Regal than ever.
He sprung her from the monastery and took her back to the palace where she soon
became gal. Song's favorite consort. Now,
just before we continue with the video today,
I do want to make quick mention today's sponsor Squarespace, couple of things.
Maybe you've got an idea for a website or a business up there in your minds.
And you're thinking maybe I should, maybe I should do that.
Maybe I should start that new project. Well, too.
The only way to figure out whether it's worth doing is to get it out there to
the world.
And another company don't think because it's scary to go and try new things.
You know, not knowing how to set up a website is not an excuse.
There are no excuses available with Squarespace.
Squarespace allows you to create a beautiful,
powerful website for whatever you're up to. You want to sell something online?
Yes. Easy to do a store. It's grass Squarespace. You want to start a podcast?
Sure. They support that too.
Now it all starts on Squarespace with a beautiful template that you can
customize to your heart's content. Or you can start from scratch,
or you can just move over from an existing domain,
making everything super easy to manage, but don't start from scratch. Well,
just use the template. Like I say, no excuses.
I you've gone through the super easy customization. For instance,
there are new updates. There's no patches. There's no tech BS to deal with.
And Squarespace also handles all of that website stuff. Podcasts. Yes. Lists.
Yes, social integrations, of course,
and much more Squarespace removes the excuses to your dreams.
So go get started today.
They've also got 24 seven support just in case you get stuck.
So you go to squarespace.com for a free trial. And when you're ready to launch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash biographics to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website.
[Inaudible].
Unbeknownst to we, when she first saw gals on not a Buddhist monastery,
there was a second reason that we would soon be welcomed back to the Imperial
palace. And her name was Mrs. Wang. This is where the story of woos.
The Chan starts to sound a bit like the plot of a George R.
Martin novel and press Wang was the de facto wife of gal song by virtue of her
top status. But she was an aging woman who had yet to bag gals on any children,
the marital relationship, if you want to call it,
that was pretty Rocky gals on preferred to spend time with a secondary
console's named chow. Not only were our jokes funnier,
but consult chow had made [inaudible] a father and breast Wang feared for her
position in the panelists.
So with a real love triangle on our hands and press Wang sought the perfect
solution to her problem would be to reintroduce a beautiful old friends like
woo. Back into the equation.
Gals on could become smitten with a new console Dow until a child would be
shoved to the side.
And that would give Wang the opportunity she needed to cement a relationship
with the emperor. Mrs. Wang's master plan. It worked perfectly. In fact,
it worked a little too well.
We have increasingly had her eyes set on seeking the power of the Chinese
throne. Came back to the Imperial palace in China,
two years off to Harvard town. We went,
[inaudible] had a son of their own named Lee Hong born in 652.
She had a second son in 653 and was pregnant with Fs daughter in
654 and breast Wang succeeded in dislodging console,
ciao from the emperor, but in doing so,
she had created an even bigger threat to her position as Empress consort.
So in 654 Empress Wang and console Shao put aside their
differences to join forces against Wu the emperor, his favorite concubine.
Nobody's quite sure what happens next. We gave birth to the emperor's daughter,
but the baby died just weeks after it was delivered.
It could have been something as simple as SIDS or crib death,
or even carbon monoxide poisoning caused by a nearby cold burning
fire and poor ventilation. We made more nefarious accusations.
She suggested that Empress Wang murdered the baby out of jealousy,
which is entirely possible when still had not born any children for the emperor
was clearly showing animosity towards whoop.
One popular theory in China today is centered around the image we as an
effective, but power hungry leader,
that school of thought suggests that we intentionally killed her own baby to see
the grounds for powerful accusations against the woman whose job she wanted.
However, the baby girl died.
The aftermath was a cold war in the Imperial palace between consort and
Empress Wang. The following year,
we accused Wang and her mother of practicing witchcraft,
which was a major offense in China at the time.
And bruh gals on banished his Empress from the palace.
We continued to gather political allies throughout Bambara bureaucracy until
finally I was on had no other choice.
He plays to both console chow and Empress Wang under arrest,
stripping the latter of her title and giving it to Wu in 655.
We became Empress columnists, saltwater, Shao,
and Wang web left to rot in prison.
Later that year gala song began to feel regrets about the harshness of his
actions.
And he considered releasing Shao and Wang and press where you're sensing they
could become threats to a new found power. Secretly had the murdered,
according to some sources and press.
We ordered that the hands and feet of both women be caught off.
She then ordered that they be thrown into a VAT of wine where they drowned and
press. We spent the next five years, smartly consolidating a power in 656.
She convinced gala's song to designate the eldest son, Lee Hong,
as the crown Prince set to the throne previously,
it had been Gallo song's oldest son,
who he had conceived with another of his concubines after she spent years
exiling unfriendly bureaucrats and arresting the children of rival concubines.
We finally got a shot at wielding some real power and pro gals on wasn't a
particularly effective realist to begin with, but by 660,
he began to be infrequently capacitated by headaches and blankness.
He remains in his chamber for weeks on end,
allowing Empress Wu to meet with local officials and make rulings in his stet.
And so Chinese bureaucrats began to plead their cases before the Empress and
much to their shock. She was an adept ruler,
thanks to Woo's comprehensive education. As a young girl, the adult,
we had the necessary historical and cultural context to relate to the embars
middle managers on a wide variety of issues.
When Galzin returned from his health problems. After months of rest,
he was pleasantly surprised to discover that as impressive ruled evenly and
effectively in his stead wound knew how to make the most of our moments in power
going forward.
She was considered a virtual equal to Ember a gal song in terms of Regency and
political power. I completely unprecedented and unparalleled feet.
And most of world history let alone that of Imperial China,
traditional Chinese wisdom and confusion schools of thoughts,
both explicitly stated that a woman could not possibly be suited for the
throne. Yet.
Emperor Wu was outperforming even her own Imperial counterparts of the day.
And for us,
we continue to prove ourself more effective regions as the Tang dynasty fostered
some of the greatest poets and scholars in Chinese history,
but she also continued to show how ruthless she could be in protecting her power
and punishing her enemies.
Many of the stories about w have been distorted throughout the centuries after
our death, as it was common for confusion, historians,
to offer historical lessons to young princes in the form of parables from
Imperial history.
These lessons were really kind to those who use up to power and woo,
whatever else she was.
It was definitely a use up up after all you don't rise from fifth ranked
concubine do Empress without, and little bit.
If you're surfing D for that reason,
it's hard to know how much fiction is mixed in with the facts from 1500 years
ago. But some pretty wild stories are passed down about Wu in the
23 year periods,
where she reigned as the real substantive power behind the throne.
One story recounts out,
she consulted with a Taoist sorcerer named Xing Shen seeking to
benefit from his knowledge of witchcraft,
the same crime she had accused and breast Wang over so many years earlier when a
unit reported this information. So gala zone,
he was angry and began planning to depose was Empress console to just as he did
with Wang,
but we'll used a feminine charms to talk the malleable gal zone out of his
decision.
Instead turning his eye on the confidence who had convinced gals on do consider
deposing her in the first place,
three of them were killed and she forced the fourth gala songs, eldest son,
Lee Zhang, the former crown Prince to commit suicide.
So how about the crown Prince Lee hall?
He was Wu's eldest son who she burst back during the first days of the war
with Empress wag,
homeless have been confident in his status as crown Prince and son of the
Empress consorts because he voiced his opinion that his mother should dial back
her interference in gals songs, court, and the affairs of the state.
Soon after he mysteriously died, historians, believe we may have poisoned him.
Whatever. The reason we wouldn't gals on hats,
a name and new crown Prince selecting a youngest son DJ,
a story from the six seventies recounts,
how she had a falling out with a daughter-in-law the princess of Shao who was
married to a third son, but also happened to be the emperor's cousin.
I know that the relationship between wives and the mother-in-law can be
complicated,
but we chose to take out her frustration on princess jowl by accusing
her of vague crimes with minimal evidence, arresting her,
and then eventually starving at a death.
When a son became understandably frustrated with his mother, killing his wife,
she accused him of treason and exiled him,
whatever the truth behind all these stories,
it's clear that we was a woman who refused to,
to dampen her ambition on account of her agenda.
Her personal and political life may have been rocked by some behavior that would
make Cersei Lannister blush,
but it's hard to deny the fact that she remains an extremely effective ruler
even while technically operating behind the ineffective gals.
On finally in the final days of 683 CE and borough [inaudible]
died at the age of 56, they usually assumed the throne at the age of 27.
Dad. She no.
Longer rule as Empress, calm salt as the mother of the emperor.
She had a new title, Empress dowager, or queen mother, despite the title change.
Our plan was the same rule. China as the power behind the throne,
her son cliche was renamed as emperor Zhang Zong and the Tang dynasty
continued on this plan, worked great for all of six weeks.
The last will and Testament of gala zone called for his inexperienced son to
look to his brilliance mother in the matters of state.
But the newly crowned emperor Zhang zone was more interested in listening to his
new wife way John's own moved to make his father-in-law the prime minister
and began rebelling against the will of Wu a move that was candidly. Well,
pretty stupid. We didn't blow up the septum Baylor or anything,
but she did call on her bureaucratic allies to rectify the situation.
Essentially unwilling her some status as emperor through sheer political
force. Everyone involved with [inaudible] was forced into exile,
including the promoted father-in-law.
And we actually forced her second son lesion to commit suicide.
All this cleared the way for our youngest and most pliable son Lee down to
become the new emperor was able to hold onto her political power.
First as Empress dowager,
then as regions for the newly crowns and root zone [inaudible] was
a true puppet. He was not allowed to go to court.
Officials were barred from meeting with him and he played no part in the affairs
of state in 685.
We've had a mass absolute power over the Chinese empire ruse on for his part.
It learns a great deal from watching his mother and older brothers.
His mother offered him the full Imperial powers of his position in 686.
And he wisely denied being interested in obtaining them in any meaningful way
on was savvy enough to understand what many others did not.
We was never going to give up our power and to being a toothless emperor was
still much better than, you know, being sent to live in exile.
During a decade as queen mother,
we began to see local rebellions that chafed against her continued consolidation
of power.
One exile in Eastern China drew great public support for his mutinous conflicts
prompting one adviser to point out that we could dissolve the whole conflict by
returning power to our son and brewery zone strategically.
It was a wise observation politically.
It was the sort of thing you never wanted to say out loud to whoop.
She arrested the advisor,
took down the names of everyone who spoke out in his defense,
then arrested them to and executed the lot of them.
We began installing beautiful,
ornate copper mailboxes outside our palaces and other official government
buildings so that people could anonymously report dangerous behavior. She put,
inadvertently created a medieval four runner to the Chinese secret police,
which she used to hunt down and exile or kill the scores of people she believed
were rising up against her.
It was the cap on decades of harsh authoritarian actions,
many of which are difficult to defend,
but it's important to remember that that young girl born [inaudible] has a
massive obstacle to overcome her womanhood.
No woman had ever risen to the throne of Imperial China,
and she knew that she had to maintain a ruthless edge that never dolls.
If she wanted to formally sit on the throne before her death,
the secret police was the final stepping up plan.
She used the information from the copper mailboxes to arrest and eliminate a
political enemies, regardless of how accurate the information was by 690,
she had removed anyone who might consider voicing opposition to our queen
shepherds, thus peacefully deposed her final son, seizing formal power.
We wish it was no longer the defacto Empress of China.
She was the first and only Monarch and assumed a more appropriate title.
Woozy tan,
The rules for most of our life as the power behind Tang embers were herself was
not of the Tang dynasty as such. When she ascended the throne,
she declared herself to be the wounds yet. Jan,
the first Ambrose of the new Shao dynasty,
the dynasty would last for 15 years until the end of her life from 690 to seven
Oh five. By the time we formally became Empress regnant,
she was already 66 and advanced age, particularly for the seventh century,
much of her rule as Ambrose regnant mirrored her earlier decades at court,
she poisoned exiles and killed political opponents to maintain a position while
making smart economic decisions for the embark.
She faced military challenges from Bango tribes to the North and the Tibetan men
part of the South while she didn't soundly defeat,
either force China did continue to thrive. Even if it was through a bit of luck,
the Mongo tribes were defeated by a third party from the steps and the Tibetan
government crumbled from within. And I find all years,
palace injury focused on Wu's line of succession.
Many of the bureaucrats in the Imperial Wells felt that we should designate a
Tang edge to restore the dynasty.
While her family pushed to formalize we family power by passing power to a blood
relative, strangely, she seemed to favor neither option.
Instead favoring a pair of young brothers named Zhang,
Yeezy and Zhang Chang Jong.
These brothers may have been serving her as younger sexual partners over the
course of our 15 years as Empress remnants.
They slowly grew in power until one day in the spring of 705,
CE the bureaucrats around,
we could no longer allow her to groom these two randos to be our success at,
we was 81 years old and in poor health and finally a coup against her worked out
an Alliance of Wu family members, Chinese generals,
and politically savvy bureaucrat storms.
The palace murdered the Jang brothers and seized the throne from Wu who has
moved on to go and do a location in the palace. In the following days,
the crew released a statement and we was named that Paolo had written to a third
son, Lee Shan, who had ruled for six weeks as emperor zone.
He returned to the throne for five years. They,
one of Wu's nephews continued to challenge them for power,
whereas removal restored the Tang dynasty,
which flourished for another 200 years.
Thanks in large part to we use intelligent leadership.
Her own attempts at a dynasty is contested by many historians.
Traditional Chinese historians recognize the second child dynasty,
the jowl restoration, but many considerate,
nothing more than an interlude in the much more politically impactful Tang
timeline. Since the term dynasty explicitly calls for more than one roulette,
we were self died later that year in December of seven Oh five,
she was interred with a former defacto husband and borough gals song at the
jingling mausoleum outside of the Imperial capital.
Wu's effective rain and raffle palace demeanor are still controversial today.
Centuries of stories twisted by sexism and confusion bosses painted Wu as a
bloodthirsty Empress whose only goal was power, but modern takes on a life,
a more nuanced recognizing both the violence methods and her skill.
As a governor, often we use death in 7.5.
It didn't take long for another woman to attempt to follow the wounds yet 10
playbook and press consort way wife of embryos,
Zhang Zong poisoned her husband and attempted to seize power.
She sees the throne alongside her daughter, but only for a matter of hours,
accrue Rose up in opposition to our COO and she was killed hours later.
It was a nice dry bus.
Not quite enough after all the throne couldn't be seized by any women.
It took a special blends of smarts, beauty ambition,
and cruelty to become the Chinese Empress and to no one had that.
Quite like woo.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe also.
Please do check it out. Fantastic sponsors,
Squarespace making this video possible link below. Thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].